[Music]
so
[Music]
coming up on fyi from a trip to the
theater to the latest cinema release
we've got loads of info on how to stay
entertained this summer i will write my
diary to this girl of mystery and name
will be kitty
but can we afford to do the things we
love this summer the cost of everything
is rising is the government going to
help struggling families
[Music]
this is fyi the weekly news show where
we bring you all the latest info on all
the big stories and investigate possible
fake news this week we found two
interesting photos of space that have
been doing the rounds online now we did
some digging as we weren't sure whether
these photos were real or just fake news
see what you think
first up is this photo of the planet
mars with what looks like a giant smiley
face on it what is this fat or funny
photo editing
or what about this picture shared online
by a well-known scientist apparently
it's a new picture of proxima centauri
the nearest star to earth
one of these photos is fake but which
one we'll reveal all later
[Music]
so we all know how important the nhs is
and how hard our doctors and nurses work
especially during the pandemic yeah
absolutely and did you know in the uk we
have one of the best children's
hospitals in the world it's called the
great ormond street hospital and it's
celebrating its 170th birthday it's a
place that's really important to loads
of children across the country including
fyi's thomas who has spent a lot of time
there he went back to visit for the day
[Music]
come and check out a place that is very
special to me
this is great ormond streets children's
hospital it was the first hospital set
up just for kids in the uk and this year
it's 170 years old
it first opened its doors in 1852 with
just 10 beds now it treats nearly 300
000 children each year i should know as
i was one of them thanks to this place
i'm able to run and be as active as i am
i grew up with a rare knee condition
which limited my movement
it's meant that over the past 10 years
i've had 10 procedures at great ormond
street and somehow they made it
enjoyable we're here to see some of the
activities that patients are getting to
do the prey street
[Music]
instead of the cars going past the road
it's been like closed off so that people
can be here and like just have a nice
time and play and stuff how important
are experiences like today for patients
and why
i've been in hospital for six weeks it's
like really fun like just to come
outside i like play for a couple hours
instead of just sit inside
it makes it so that the patients at
great ormond street can like kind of
forget about what's happening in the
hospital and just like relax and play
play street is just one of the fun
activities that helps children get
through tough times
three years ago i needed to get my leg
amputated and then i needed help getting
used to life without a leg but
throughout that the staff made my time
as fun as possible this is my favorite
nurse danny and then
this is the man who chopped my leg off
what type of things do you do on the
wall to make
children stay a bit more enjoyable we've
got the lovely play team we make things
as fun as possible so like your physio
and things it wasn't where it was just
walking up and down stairs there was
lots of games involved i think the
important thing for us here is to
try and make the journey for the
children and the families easier you
were one of the most resilient and
probably one of the smartest children
that i've had the pleasure to look after
and the fact that you came to a lot of
these decisions yourself
you're really one of the bravest kids
that i know and i'm really grateful to
have been able to look after you your
journey here was a very long journey you
were so determined and despite
everything you carried on thank you
because you're the one who's actually
made me want to come back
yeah you guys just made it a hundred
times better
[Music]
if you want to know more about the
national health service and how it works
check out our i don't get it explainer
on our web page
we've been investigating loads of issues
that can be complicated like racism
terrorism and the war in ukraine just
head to first.news fyi or sky kids on
demand
[Music]
during the summer there are always loads
of great films that aren't there yeah we
like the local one in the cinemas now
it's called where is anne frank it's all
about her famous diaries she was 12
years old and wrote about her
experiences of being a jew and hiding
from the nazis during the second world
war her diaries went on to become
international bestsellers and had been
read by generations of children
during the second world war the german
nazi party led by adolf hitler murdered
6 million jewish people from countries
across europe in an attempt to wipe out
the jewish population it is known as the
holocaust
the jewish people had done nothing wrong
they were targeted simply because they
were jewish
fyi scarlett has seen the film and has
got more info for us what are you
waiting for anne open your presents oh
that's so lovely if you've read her
diaries you'll know that anne frank had
an imaginary friend called kitty
in this beautiful film set 80 years
later kitty comes out of the diary and
becomes a real person
she's shocked to see how child refugees
are still being treated get in the truck
do everything you can
to save one single soul from han i got
to catch up with ruby stokes who voiced
the character of kitty hi ruby thank you
so much for joining me thank you for
having me what really struck me about
this film is just how relevant it is to
present day recently i went to poland to
meet with ukrainian refugees i feel like
it relates a lot to what anne frank and
kitty went through
yeah i mean that's kind of what the
whole film's about in terms of drawing
parallels between past and present and i
think hopefully like people will leave
you know after watching the film with an
awareness
of you know what's going on today as
well do you think we've learned from
past mistakes when it comes to war i
don't necessarily think we have learnt
the difference is that people
are more public about their support for
those in like war zones you know lots of
jewish people didn't have places of
refuge that they could go to you know
otto anne's father had the help of his
work colleagues they were able to be in
the secret annex but a lot of people
didn't have that what did you learn
about anne frank whilst you were playing
the voice of kitty oh i learned a lot i
learned how like fiercely loyal she is
and how much she loves and she's very
funny and she's
an extraordinary young woman who
is very imaginative and is very powerful
with her words well thank you so much
for speaking to me i think the film is
absolutely amazing and i really
appreciate your time well thank you
scarlet
what do you see peter
i see the allied forces they're coming
to liberate us and you
i see angels peter
thanks scarlett it looks like a great
film so braden are you a fan of history
yeah i find it super interesting yeah me
too have you heard of horrible histories
of course i have who hasn't well they've
got the tv show they've got the books
and now they've got a theater show and i
wanted to see if it worked on stage so
check this out
[Music]
i am henry tudor earl of richmond tidy
but what's so terrible about the tudors
and does it work as a stage show
well i'm getting to meet the actors to
find out you can count them on one hand
great to meet you hello so what can we
expect from the show you can expect
songs dances sketches blood gore bit of
poo are we allowed to say poo to you
hopefully
so guys we've got the books the tv show
and now we've got the stage show but
what does the stage show bring the books
and tv show don't
well i think there's an immediacy with
with the audience they're there and
we've got bits in the show where they'll
have to join in and
you've got to be louder this side than
that side and there's more interaction
in a way with us yeah what's your top
terrible tutor fact you guys can share
with me oh territude of fact one of the
nice facts i like is the mad medicines
that they used to use
uh in those days and thought they could
cure people one of them was for deafness
they used to pour a a pint of fox grease
down your ear and the guts of a
dead hair well a dead hair a red hair
yeah specifically yeah oh lovely yeah so
any old hair won't do it has to be a red
one yeah good luck and i'll see you on
stage oh thank you so much so nice to
meet you
i had the heart and stomach of a king
and a king of england too
now let's take a selfie i'm here with my
little sister elia and we're just about
to watch the show you looking forward to
it yeah come on let's go
[Applause]
so we've just finished watching the show
and we really love it what do you think
else i think it was great i liked it
because um you always learn a lot of
facts um from like a lot a long time ago
and i like all the singing and dancing i
love singing and dancing as well
[Music]
well that show that fun maya yeah it
really was i didn't think it was going
to work as a stage show but it really
did but here's the thing summer holidays
aren't always fun for everybody because
trips to the theatre to the cinema and
theme parks have gone up crazily since
last year i mean it is it's madness
really it's crazy prices and the rising
food and energy cost means that
obviously families are prioritizing
paying the bills rather than going on
fun trips out which means you know loads
of kids are just missing out yeah and i
read that 43 councils across england
have either scrapped or reduced food
vouchers for kids who have free school
meals i mean loads of people are so
angry about it i bet
everything's getting more expensive
fueling ingredients for food are in
short supply because of the war in
ukraine and the pandemic russia has
agreed to let grain leave ukrainian
ports to reach countries most in need of
it and hopefully we will see the costs
of some foods go down
we got hold of asha a youth ambassador
for the food foundation charity who
campaigns for affordable and healthy
food for everyone and she's joining us
now hi asha thank you for joining us hi
it's a pleasure to be here
so what do you think the government
should be doing to help struggling
families this summer i think the
government should really listen to what
we need instead of assuming because we
aren't getting what we should be getting
and it's important now that
during the cost of living crisis that
everyone is being hurt so your family
has experience struggling to afford food
right
how did you guys manage through the
summer holidays it was definitely hard
but it was to the point where we would
go around to my nana's house and she
would have to feed us we would always
have to ask family members to offer us
support and often my mum would go
without food which is really hard to see
because everyone deserves to eat well no
one should have to experience that
should they no i can't even imagine how
hard that would have been for you i mean
thank you so much for sharing you know
everything with us thank you for letting
me share it with you
bye
well we got in touch with the government
to ask them what they were doing to help
families over this summer and they said
that their holiday activities and food
programme offers enriching activities
and healthy meals to disadvantaged
children during the school holidays and
that they are providing over 37 billion
to address rising costs targeting help
to households with the greatest need
and if you want to hear more about ash's
story and other families who have
struggled to afford food just head to
our webpage first dot news slash fyi and
click on the conversation link
so did you guess which of these photos
were fake
this photo of what was said to be the
nearest star to earth is fake news it's
actually a close-up picture of a slice
of chorizo
the scientist who posted the photo said
he did it to remind people to be
cautious of potentially fake pictures
online
which means this picture of mars smiling
is fact the face is actually a crater
caused by a meteorite hitting the
planet's surface it's even called the
happy face crater and is 160 miles wide
that's one big smiley face
[Music]
we love getting videos from you and
hearing what you've been up to and this
summer there have been loads of major
events happening that you guys have been
getting involved in yeah and one of them
has been the joust elena the largest and
the longest-running muslim convention in
the uk
around 30 000 people attend the event
each year and it's mainly run by loads
of young muslim volunteers who help give
out food and water to worshipers and
some of you want to tell us why the
festival is so important to you i came
to jail star because it's an amazing way
for to for yourself to
increase your spirituality and it's
really fun they come over from all over
the country and they come together to
spend time with each other create bonds
and increase community
well from one big event to another the
commonwealth games have just come to an
end but fyi viewer janella louise wanted
to share her experience of the games
with awesome
hi fred
luisia i live in birmingham which is the
current host to the commonwealth games i
was lucky enough to get tickets to both
the netball and the athletics where i
was supporting the caribbean islands and
england this is because my grandparents
are from barbados and i am a proud
english girl
barbados didn't do so well in netball
but jamaica had made it to the finals
shooting for gold
i also enjoyed seeing the big bull from
the opening ceremony and meeting some of
the medalists
watching the netboard definitely
inspired me to carry on playing at polar
school thanks fyi that's all from me
janelle louise
laters bye
thanks janella louise well whatever
you're up to this summer have a great
one that's about it for more see you
next week